very simple he's gonna say his name you
guess his religion or his way of life
you ready are you ready yes
Marco Croatia Troy oh that's uh that's a
nationality Christian Marco Serban Marco
Marco sounds Orthodox guess again
wait first you said should have been
rather Slava Orthodox Marco Catholic
he's gonna say his name you guess his
religion Marco Marco Christianity
Marco Catholic Marco Mirza Marco that's
a nationality so we're looking for a
religion Christian try again muscling
congratulations beautiful yes yeah you
surprised yes yeah why because I never
saw I never heard mark queen muscling
yeah religion so you know what Muslim
means right yes one who submits to the
will of God one who submits surrenders
to God when I crossed the pedo bogo
right he produce a BOGO he's Muslim he
accepted Mohammed is the last and final
messenger he accepted Islam mashallah
congratulations thank you thank you
no Jewish Muslim but he made it yes it
took a few attempts but he got it yes
try again Muslim luck buddy
you got it on the second try good job
good job yeah all right
if you have liked Croatian name Serbian
name doesn't necessarily have to be that
you're not not Christian or Orthodox you
can be Muslim Serbian Muslim Croatian
Muslim its religion it's not nationality
so it doesn't matter
beautiful thank you try again Marco
Orthodox
try again prowess la mañana one more
time
Greek my diaper necessarily Jia never
Chabot Marco Muslim an he's a Muslim
this is Marco the Muslim ha ha yay
because remember remember a Muslim is
one who submits to the will of God he
submitted to the will of God he became a
much loved Marco Muslim he got it yes ok
good you got it you got it because the
Muslim is one who submits to the will of
the creator of heavens and earth Allah
you got it good job on his face how do
you see it on his face I don't know I
have a feeling you know just feel it try
again
Marco yeah it could be Christian so he
got to one more okay so a taste he's
Muslim
we're dispelling the myths here this is
a great example see Marco can be Muslim
because a Muslim is one who submits to
the will of the creator the heavens in
the earth my name is Marco charity let's
try again he got it on the second try
beautiful my name is Marco yes so I
understood the question that probably
when he was walking with you I know you
I watched your mission a lot of times
barik alaa fake and and I probably guess
he's Muslim yes if we had a prize would
give it to you got it but you already
put it together so my name is Marco he's
Muslim he got he already knew but thanks
for participating because you've seen
him you've seen him on TV not on TV but
my friend knows him so I I follow him on
Facebook and
on internet as well thank you yeah keep
going
Buddhist but yes mr. cover just religion
Catholic Catholic you didn't try Hindu
he doesn't look like him going you
didn't get it right yet I don't know how
many it's one of them it's - I'll give
you a hint it's the fast
not yet I'm gonna give you this it was
the religion of Jesus it was the
religion the way of Moses it was the way
of Abraham is the way of when I say the
way he submitted his will to God
definition that is a Muslim which was
he's Muslim that's Marco I'm Muslim
- so Marco the Muslim really because
this is my source focuses
he doesn't look like Muslim I mean by
name by name by name yeah my name is
Larson and Don and I'm I'm Muslim -
thank you thank you for taking he's
gonna say his name you guess his
religion Marco or whatever you whatever
comes to mind from his name Christian
nope try again because a Muslim is one
who submits to the will of the crater he
could be Serbian he could be creation he
could be polish he gonna be American it
transcends all the National
nationalities good try
thank you thank you yes first of mine it
comes to my mind like Muslim but I
didn't want to tell it because I didn't
want to discriminate the person but you
afraid you'd be offended if you said
Muslim for the from the start yes I
wanna be sure
not Christian then I can see in Muslims
very forceful you know to be and this is
a good example to be you know to take
care of the other people feelings oh
that's nice of you thank you thank you
so much my name is Marco what would you
pursue usually I would presume he's the
you know Croat or a Serb but since I
know that name doesn't determine
somebody's belonging you know I already
know enough you know like so I would
guess maybe he could have been monetary
store Muslim you know like regardless of
his name that's what we're trying to do
we're trying to show that Islam
transcends the nationalism that you
could be served and you could be Muslim
one who submits to the will of God you
could be Croatian like he is and you can
submit your will to the crater that's
what a Muslim just like in Arab world
you have Christians with Semitic Arabic
names and people are confused with that
because it's a cultural thing you know
many people don't know that so in this
particular case it happened at life of
him personally because that was
interviewing him once also for my
newspaper oh you you were interviewing
yeah like 10 years ago or something like
that no I think based on that book he
brought he promoted in Sarajevo and I
was in journalism I'm still is just not
so much as before and I enjoyed him
because he brought the interesting book
then I saw your interview on YouTube
with him and then I found that he
embraced Islam you know like and then
but already I really knew that name is
does not determine somebody's faith or
belonging which many people I know that
basically in Islam you could be called
in any name that belongs to any culture
in the world as long as it doesn't have
some bad meaning or you know meaning
that is Haram or anything like that you
know
apart from that could be any culture
because Islam is universal as we know or
as we should know at least so many
people don't know that's it thank you no
thank you for sharing that with us let's
do some takeaways we had that brother he
guessed everything except Muslim and
then he makes them nationality with it
yeah he's a good example how we asked
you ask him you know to guess the
religion and he instead automatically
said not a religion but nationality he
said he's a Serb he said no no no
religion ah and he's a karate rah no he
has had to repeat it to him now
to put no
this is an example how this religion and
the national identity ethnic identity
are mixed and confused and the this they
are stuck together but they shouldn't be
talked together there are separated
things we also talked to us about people
when you and others have accepted Islam
they automatically they start to
associate you of being a Turk right
right this is especially in these places
the usual kind of response you know now
you accepted Islam now you got to be
Turk you know which is absolute closest
yeah I'm still a crowd and there are
many famous crowd Muslims in in history
and but people just try to ignore and
you know they stuck to this program you
know if you a crowd you must be Catholic
and there's no other way around it and
if you're served in your Orthodox and
what was the name you name you name some
very famous people who were Croatian
they were Serbian and they achieved a
very high status in the yes there are
plenty of especially crowd Houston para
Herat this means Rodney's crowd Ibrahim
Pasha cravat and so on there are lots of
most of them who achieved the top
position the top position just below the
Sultan the big Vizier and they they keep
they kept the the title I'm gonna I'm
gonna say his name you guess his
religion you ready okay so I'm when I
guess isn't I'm gonna say his name and
then you guess the religion ready yeah
my name is Marco you got a good job
alright
nice to meet you you too Salaam alaikum
the point is this is the proof
historical proof that is if they
accepted Islam there were high ranking
officials in the Ottoman Empire and
nobody forced them to give up their
national identity no quite the contrary
they kept it in their title and they
were proud of it and nobody nobody said
that they cannot do it so this is the
proof that how things really are
unfortunately people have programmed the
other way the wrong way and this is not
only the we did this religion and
ethical identity we will see how will
they react to this cover of the book we
have we had a unique situation a man I
think front from Malaysia right but you
can see it was a little bit different he
wasn't from the surrounding culture here
and he reacted different yes because
this is it also allowed he said Marco uh
and he says how Lake whom I responded
aleikum Salaam and so he he figured that
very easy say peace be with you
yes yes and he wasn't bothered with this
local program you know for him may my
record ever doesn't be nothing you know
so he's free of this you know wrong
perception